well that's an interesting question uh
and
there
let's start with with with uh
let's say they're the employees they're
the shareholders
and they're the uh other industry
participants which can really in in the
upstream part of the oil and gas
business are not customers they're
really joint ventures
and uh
the problem of course is always that the
individual hearing the truth
cannot
assimilate it correctly because of
ignorance or lack of attention or
whatever and therefore overreacts
and of course that's a possible downside
but
i think
i've always been so wary of
rationalizations
excusing
deviations from basic ethics that i said
we'll just have to take
take the possibility of of of that
because it's such a slippery slope when
you start convincing yourself of
deviations from
from
probity that
it gets easier and easier because what
happens you say well
you know they wouldn't understand that
so i won't tell them that and that's
that's this quarter and the next quarter
would be slightly larger deviation and
it's just the human mind my view of the
human mind at work is that it
it can be extremely perverse so the
employees i worried about least
you know i knew that if they wanted to
if they revealed some of these very
sensitive pieces of information it could
hurt us competitively but then again we
chose people that we firmly believed
were upright
solid citizens
then when it came to the shareholders
for for better or worse
it really is true that most of the
shareholders you know did yearn you know
did you meet your estimates
and um we actually toyed with
um showing the shareholders the sort of
stuff that we generated internally based
on what are called monte carlo
simulations where you start to actually
end up with a histogram of your expected
production in a given
a given year but we decided that maybe
about one percent of the people would
understand it and and
we'd get calls back saying oh so the 50
so the top part that that's what you're
going to have right you're going to have
that that's what you're going to have
right and then we'd have to explain
that's not really you know this so we
finally gave up trying to have a
different approach to disclosure which i
felt would have been more fruitful and
decided we were just going to have um
no games but nothing more no
breakthroughs in terms of the degree of
information we conveyed
to our
shareholders in terms of
our joint ventures
our view is we were in it for the long
haul
we were a good partner
we expected them to be good partners
and we were always going to tell
them the absolute truth because we knew
they could
analyze things they would be able to
understand what we were saying
and that we picked our partners on a
basis that we believed that they would
be able to give us
their reason the point of view if if
they were asked
just as we would if we were asked so
what happens in the oil and gas business
typically there's an operator who takes
prime responsibility and then there's
some working interest partners
who
don't control the actual operations of
the well except under extraordinary
circumstances
generally aren't asked their opinions we
tended to to talk to ours more than most
uh and
you know with all three groups
we uh
we just we disclosed as much as we felt
we could without sacrificing
our competitive position
uh
we didn't disclose where we were headed
and you know what the next trend we were
headed toward but basically we disclosed
more than i've ever seen anyone else
disclose to people we thought were
uh worthy of of of listening to it